the mind-blowing finale of I am NOT okay
with this left us with many questions
about SIDS powers and the mysterious
figure
yippie Kay we'll be lovers I'm John and
in this video I'll be breaking all of
that down and explaining the secret
conspiracy that led to Sid superpowers
plus season two theories obviously
spoilers ahead so take care if you
haven't seen the show yet the first
season ends with a literal bang whence
its powers explode brats head at the
school homecoming as gruesome as it is
it's also designed to be kind of funny
because Brad unsuspectingly predicted
his own demise earlier that same day
let's just say that today it's gonna be
good mind-blowing when Sid flees the
scene she returns to the tower she went
to the previous time her powers became
massively out of control as she
contemplates her future we hear
whispering voices and a dark cloud of
particles arrives on the platform behind
her taking on a human form who are you
should I be afraid they should be afraid
so who is this strange shadowy figure
that's been stalking Sid this entity can
dissolve into a dark cloud as we saw
what it was watching Sid after her
training session with Stan on the one
hand the show seems to hint it could be
her father or a vision of him for
example when Sid mentions to her school
counselor that she thought a man had
been following her miss Capriati asks
Sid if he looked like her father and
basically suggests that the figure was
just a grief hallucination of her dead
dad caused by her feelings of loss over
him however when this mystery figure
finally appears in front of Sid on the
platform
she doesn't recognize him we also know
that SIDS mother said that when her
father was still alive he believed
somebody was following him too curiously
in the graphic novel that the show is
based on a shadowy black form appears in
a scene where sit is having sex and in
the comic it's its powers which
unconsciously create this menacing
entity so in the TV show could this
ghostly figure be something that Sid is
created from our inner abilities without
realizing when Sid and Stan are
reviewing the stolen library security
cam footage stand even comments that
just looks like your shadow whoever or
whatever it might be the ending is
setting this mystery man up as a mentor
figure for Sid in the second season Stan
who already thinks of Sid as a superhero
pointed out
that this is classic comic book
storytelling so each of these comics
there's an unknown visitor fast sarah
wise old sage some form of a mentor
figure you know who visits the hero
explains their abilities the mythology
behind them how they can harness those
powers for good this being is probably
there to help sid properly understand
how to control her powers and maybe even
harness them in a positive way so what
if I really am a freak I could be okay
with that I mean if I really can make a
nose bleed with my brain then maybe it
can be used for good so far Sid struggle
to manage her powers she's tried
blocking out negative thoughts and
smoking weed which seemed to help
somewhat but these aren't real permanent
solutions as any type of strong emotion
or panic trigger her powers in
unpredictable and dangerous ways season
one then is SIDS superhero origin story
and the show heavily hints that she
received them from her father when Stan
tries to figure out how Sid got her
powers he suggests that sometimes a
person inherits their abilities and SIDS
mother also tells her when it comes to
your dad you have this gift
there are also obvious parallels in
terms of their shared telekinetic powers
between Sid and eleventh and stranger
things whose own powers originated from
the clandestine MKULTRA experiments
carried out on her mother however the
origin of SIDS father's powers is as yet
unknown in fact the show's co-creator
and director Jonathan Entwistle has said
there's a much bigger under the surface
conspiracy to do with the powers that
goes back much further which makes me
wonder whether SIDS father was
experimented on by the military after he
joined the Marines and when Stan is
trying to figure out the origin for SIDS
powers one of the possibilities he
mentions is secret military experiments
its father could have been involved in
covert military research and trials
designed to turn him into a kind of
super soldier one of the best-known
comic book characters who underwent this
type of experiment is Steve Rogers aka
Captain America another hint towards
experimentation or perhaps a chemical
accident being the cause of her father's
powers is that we get a number of scenes
and SIDS chemistry class as the
temperature increases
if an atom loses one or more electrons
it becomes oxidized
and the blackboard behind him is also
filled with numerous details about acid
and alkaline reactions we also learned
that during her father's final tour he
was the only human being who survived an
enormous explosion what if that
explosion was set off by some kind of
fire weapon that triggered a mutation in
him alternatively the explosion might
have gone off next to a chemical
facility and killed everyone else but
gave him powers or perhaps he'd already
been experimented on along with others
and the explosion was deliberately
engineered to test whether any of them
would survive the blast and only he did
x-men characters like Wolverine and
Deadpool received superhuman healing
abilities after being experimented on in
fact I am NOT okay with this has
numerous allusions to the x-men from
Stan's not men comic book The Wolverine
like spiked gloves that SIDS brother
designs of his superhero suit and the
school is also home of the Wolverines
comic book characters have often
received their powers through accidents
or mutations daredevil got his powers
when he was blinded during a chemical
accident and Carol Danvers aka Captain
Marvel was an ordinary human who
received her powers when she absorbed
the energy from an experimental
Lightspeed engine that blew up and
there's also Stan's spider tails comic
referencing the radioactive arachnid
bite that gave spider-man his abilities
at the end of the season when the
mystery figure tells Sid they should be
afraid it could be referring to the
people involved in the conspiracy rather
than the townspeople for example if it
is the ghost of her father he could be
looking for revenge he could have even
been murdered and his death made to look
like a suicide
remember he never left a note another
possibility is that there are
supernatural or even alien forces at
play here given the mystery man's
ability to disappear into thin air
there's a hint to this in the poster for
the movie they came from beyond space
which is displayed quite prominently in
Stan's room in that movie space aliens
attempt to enslave humans by possessing
them whether Sid will be able to keep
her powers under the radar in the second
season is unclear because her diary
which Brad was reading out went missing
on the dance floor during the panic
after his head exploded it'll be
interesting to see how Brad's death is
explained by investigators but
suspicion may fall on CID given how he
was ranting at her just before he died
especially if her diary ends up in the
hands of someone who decides to reveal
her secret to fellow students teachers
or the police or perhaps even ends up
blackmailing her about it now if you've
read the original graphic novel you
might be thinking that ultimately SIDS
journey will end in tragedy because
spoilers for the comic book Sid commits
suicide when she discovers she can't
handle her powers
however Entwistle has specifically said
that the Netflix version of the story
will not be as macabre and will instead
expand the world of the graphic novel to
be honest a suicide storyline as the
final destination for Sid would be a
rather bleak way to treat a character
who's not only grappling with grief but
also confronting her burgeoning
sexuality and feelings of social
isolation who could hopefully still find
a path to dealing with all that
Entwistle has also said that while the
comic is a story about mental illness
and essentially suicide what he wanted
to do with the show was build out the
back story of how Sid got to that point
and take all the elements of a journey
of somebody being confused by lots of
different things in their life and make
a different type of genre show so did
the ending of I am NOT okay with this
blow your mind and who do you think the
mystery figure is leave your thoughts
and theories in the comments below if
you enjoyed this than a thumbs up and a
share a hugely appreciated tapleft for
my latest Netflix videos on lock and key
stranger things and chilling adventures
of Sabrina what a pride for another
video you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers